Have you ever wondered what happens when someone in England visits the world Science festivals webpage?
First their computer needs to ask the world science festival server for a copy of that webpage
The computer sticks this request into a virtual envelope called a packet,  wrapped with specific information about that request
including the world Science Festival's IP address
The computer sends this packet out of the house and below the street via large underground copper wires
It passes through small regional networks before ending up here at Tellehouse North in London
Tella House North is England's main internet hub the IP address on this packet tells the hub that the world science festival server is
actually in Los Angeles.
So Tella house north sends the packet out as light across the atlantic, over fibre optic cables very deep beneath the ocean
The packet ends up here 60 Hudson street, New York City the largest internet hub on the east coast
This Hub sends the packet through a series of regional networks connecting New York to Los Angeles where the world science festival server resides?
The server reads the requests and gets ready to send the webpage to England
But web pages made up of images and text are too large to send us a single packet of data
So how do we get it back to England?
imagine a group of 5,000 tourists visiting New York City in a single gigantic tour bus
They are way up in Harlem, but they want to visit the Statue of Liberty before it closes
But it's rush hour on a Friday
There's no way that giant bus is going to fit through those crazy congested streets
So they decide to get off the bus and spread out
Some take the Subway, some take cabs, a few rent bikes, and some even take Kayaks down the Hudson River
How they get there doesn't matter as long as they get there on time
Likewise for the internet to work efficiently this webpage is pulverized into thousands of tiny packets of data
Each one wrapped with all of the information it needs to rebuild itself in England
The packets are sent to LA's One Wilshire hub which checks the traffic report before sending them off
through miles and miles of [lam] they travel checking in through different hubs like
our New York city tourists, those packets don't care how they get there as long as they get there as fast as possible
Most of them will go through 60 Hudson in New York where they are redirected back to England as light?
Riding a fibre of glass as thick as a silver dollar
then back on Copper wire through regional British networks until all the package reach their destination and
and
This Epic Journey it all happens in about a second
Along with trillions upon trillions of similar Journeys that happen each and every day on this remarkable easy to take for granted
Network of Networks we call the internet